Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. T-Bing groaned. Don't get a symbologist started on Christian icons. Nothing in Christianity is original. The pre-Christian god Mithras, called the son of God and the light of the world, was born on December the 25th. He died, was buried in a rock tomb, and then resurrected in three days. By the way, December the 25th is also the birthday of Osiris, Adonis, and Dionysus. The newborn Krishna was presented with gold, frankincense, and myrrh. Now that was the renowned symbologist Sir Lee Teabing, and he is quoted in a great book of Christmas-themed scholarship. And that book is The Da Vinci Code by the renowned author, Dan Brown. Tom,
请保持警惕，注意周围环境，确保安全。蒂宾（Teabing）发出了一声呻吟。别让符号学家谈论基督教偶像。基督教中没有任何东西是原创的。前基督教神祇密特拉（Mithras），被称为上帝之子和世界之光，出生于12月25日。他死后被埋葬在岩石墓穴中，并在三天后复活。顺便说一句，12月25日也是奥西里斯（Osiris）、阿多尼斯（Adonis）和狄俄尼索斯（Dionysus）的生日。新生儿克里希纳（Krishna）收到了黄金、乳香和没药。刚才那位是著名的符号学家李·蒂宾爵士（Sir Lee Teabing），他被引用在一本关于圣诞主题学术研究的伟大著作中。那本书就是著名作家丹·布朗（Dan Brown）所著的《达芬奇密码》（The Da Vinci Code）。汤姆，
happy Christmas. Happy Christmas. And nothing says Christmas like getting friend of the show, Dan Brown, back onto the rest of history. Yeah. We love Dan Brown and we love Christmas. Yeah. He featured earlier in the air and said, we just thought today is Christmas day. So happy, happy Christmas, everyone who's listening actually on the happy day. And we thought this would be our Christmas present to you, didn't we? We'd bring Dan Brown back. Now, I don't know whether you picked this up, Tom, but that reading that I did of Salih Teabing, it was like Sir Ian McKellen was doing it.
圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐。没有什么比让节目的老朋友丹·布朗回到《历史的余味》更能代表圣诞节了。是的。我们爱丹·布朗，我们也爱圣诞节。是的。他之前在节目中出现过，我们只是觉得今天是圣诞节。所以，祝所有在这一天收听节目的朋友们圣诞快乐。我们想这应该是我们送给你们的圣诞礼物，对吧？我们把丹·布朗请了回来。现在，我不知道你有没有听出来，汤姆，我刚才读的那段李·蒂宾爵士的话，听起来就像伊恩·麦克莱恩（Ian McKellen）爵士在表演一样。
Oh, yeah. It's like listening to Gandalf. Right. Because he plays Salih Teabing in the film. Yeah, he does. So I gave him. No, it was a masterly. Thank you.
哦，是的。听起来就像甘道夫（Gandalf）。没错。因为他在电影里扮演的就是李·蒂宾爵士。是的，他确实演了。所以我给了他……不，那真是大师级的表演。谢谢。
You have clearly been sitting at my feet and learning from me. Yeah, he does. So I gave him... No, it was a masterly. Thank you. You have clearly been sitting at my feet and learning from me. Well, what a lovely Christmas present that is. Well done, grasshopper. What a lovely Christmas present to one another. Yeah. I mean, there's nothing that says Christmas to me like staring at your face several days before the big day. And so here we are. Well, of course, we are actually recording this on Christmas morning, aren't we?
你显然一直坐在我脚边向我学习。是的，他确实演了。所以我给了他……不，那真是大师级的表演。谢谢。你显然一直坐在我脚边向我学习。嗯，那真是份可爱的圣诞礼物。干得好，小蚱蜢。这对彼此来说都是一份可爱的圣诞礼物。是的。我的意思是，没有什么比在圣诞节前几天盯着你的脸看更能让我感受到圣诞气氛了。所以我们就在这里。当然，我们实际上是在圣诞节早晨录制这期节目，不是吗？
Of course we are, Tom. We got up really early today. Yeah. So there's a serious point here. Salih Teabing in this book basically says everything in Christmas, in Christianity is invented. It's all stolen from somewhere else. It was Mithras' day originally, and all the elements of the nativity story have basically been plagiarized from rival cults in the days of the Roman Empire, I suppose. And actually, Tom, the serious point is you see this idea repeated all the time.
当然是，汤姆。我们今天起得很早。是的，这里有一个严肃的观点。李·蒂宾爵士在这本书里基本上说圣诞节和基督教里的一切都是虚构的。全是从别处偷来的。它最初是密特拉的节日，圣诞故事的所有元素基本上都是从罗马帝国时期的敌对教派中剽窃来的，我想是这样。实际上，汤姆，严肃的观点在于，你经常看到这种观点被重复提及。
Yeah, it's very popular. So keen humanists and atheists are always saying, well, actually, I think you'll find that if Jesus existed, which he didn't, he definitely wasn't born on December the 25th, and everything is ripped off from Mithraism or from Sol Invictus or these other religions. Well, we did two episodes on Jesus, didn't we, last time as our festive offering? We did. And I think we agreed that Jesus probably wasn't born on the 25th of December. I mean, we don't know when he's born, and we don't know which year, but this is not quite what Sir Lee Teabing is saying.
是的，它非常流行。所以热衷的人文主义者和无神论者总是说，嗯，实际上，如果你去查一下，如果耶稣真的存在（虽然他并不存在），他绝对不是出生在12月25日，而且所有东西都是从密特拉教或“无敌太阳”（Sol Invictus）或其他宗教中抄袭来的。嗯，我们上次作为节日献礼，做了两期关于耶稣的节目，不是吗？我们做了。而且我想我们都同意耶稣可能不是出生在12月25日。我的意思是，我们不知道他什么时候出生，也不知道是哪一年，但这并不完全是李·蒂宾爵士所说的那样。
He's essentially saying that Christmas is ultimately a pagan festival and that Christians have stolen various aspects of pagan cults and kind of bundled it all together to create a kind of pagan mishmash that they're passing off as their own festival. And this is quite a popular theory, as you say. So popular that until you put me right about two years ago, I believed it to be true myself. I believed that it had been ripped off from other Roman rivals. Well, so the question of whether it's a pagan festival, I mean, that's what we're going to be looking at today. But one thing I think we can absolutely say is that it is a Roman festival. It originates as a Roman festival because obviously Jesus was born into the Roman empire and the center of early Christian activity was within the limits of the Roman empire. I mean, not exclusively, but mostly. So I think you could say that Christmas is one of the festivals that grows up over the course of Roman history, but does this make it a pagan festival? So that's the question.
他本质上是在说圣诞节最终是一个异教节日，基督徒窃取了异教崇拜的各个方面，并将它们捆绑在一起，创造了一种他们冒充为自己节日的异教大杂烩。正如你所说，这是一个相当流行的理论。流行到直到大约两年前你纠正我之前，我自己也相信它是真的。我相信它是从其他罗马竞争对手那里抄袭来的。嗯，所以关于它是否是一个异教节日的问题，我的意思是，这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。但我认为我们可以绝对肯定的一点是，它是一个罗马节日。它起源于一个罗马节日，因为显然耶稣出生在罗马帝国，而早期基督教活动的中心就在罗马帝国的范围内。我的意思是，不是全部，但大部分是。所以我认为你可以说圣诞节是随着罗马历史发展而成长起来的节日之一，但这是否使它成为一个异教节日呢？这就是问题所在。
The tantalizing question. So, I mean, there are kind of various elements to what Salih was claiming. We should remind ourselves, Salih TV obviously doesn't exist. Doesn't actually exist, no. But, you know, he's a very distinguished symbolologist, so let's cite him. So he is saying that the pre-Christian god Mithras was born on the 25th of December. Actually, he says December the 25th, doesn't he, which marks him out as American.
这是一个诱人的问题。所以，我的意思是，李·蒂宾所声称的内容有各种各样的要素。我们应该提醒自己，李·蒂宾显然不存在。实际上并不存在，没错。但是，你知道，他是一位非常杰出的符号学家，所以让我们引用他。所以他说前基督教神祇密特拉出生在12月25日。实际上，他说的是“December the 25th”，不是吗？这表明他是美国人。
That's poor, but he does. Although in the book, he's actually British, so that's another thing to chalk up to Dan Brown's mastery. Another Dan Brown solacism. Yeah, so he's saying that the pre-Christian god Mithras was born on the 25th of December, that the same date was the birth of Osiris, who is an Egyptian god, Adonis, who's a kind of Syrian god, and Dionysus, who's a Greek god.
这很糟糕，但他确实这么说了。虽然在书中，他实际上是英国人，所以这是丹·布朗“大师风范”的又一个体现。丹·布朗的又一个语病。是的，所以他说前基督教神祇密特拉出生在12月25日，同一日期也是奥西里斯（一位埃及神）、阿多尼斯（一位叙利亚神）和狄俄尼索斯（一位希腊神）的生日。
And that the baby Krishna, who is an Indian god, was presented with gold, frankincense, and myrrh. So these are gods from quite a broad range of backgrounds. So it would be amazing if all these gods were born on the same day. And so the question is, is there any ancient source at all that states that Osiris and Adonis and Dionysus were born on the 25th of December? What do you think? I have a lot of confidence in both in Lee Teabing and indeed in Dan Brown. I mean, we established earlier this year that Dan Brown
而且婴儿克里希纳（一位印度神）收到了黄金、乳香和没药。所以这些神来自非常广泛的背景。如果所有这些神都出生在同一天，那将是令人惊奇的。所以问题是，是否有任何古代文献明确指出奥西里斯、阿多尼斯和狄俄尼索斯出生在12月25日？你怎么看？我对李·蒂宾和丹·布朗都很有信心。我的意思是，我们今年早些时候确定了丹·布朗
is very rarely wrong about religious history, Tom. Well, have his senses misled him on this occasion? There is not a single ancient source that states that Osiris or Adonis or Dionysus were born on the 25th of December. Absolutely none. And in fact, Osiris, so he's a very, very significant Egyptian god. Yeah. And we talked about him in our episode on the death of Antinous, Hadrian's beloved, who drowns in the Nile. And Osiris becomes the god of the dead. And so the date of his death and the date of his birth are both seen as being very significant, rather as in the Christian story. But Osiris is not born on the same day as Jesus. It's complicated because
在宗教历史上很少出错，汤姆。嗯，他的感官在这次场合误导了他吗？没有任何一份古代文献指出奥西里斯、阿多尼斯或狄俄尼索斯出生在12月25日。绝对没有。事实上，奥西里斯，他是一位非常、非常重要的埃及神。是的。我们在关于哈德良（Hadrian）的爱人安提诺乌斯（Antinous）溺死在尼罗河中的那期节目中谈到过他。奥西里斯成为了死神。所以他的死亡日期和出生日期都被视为非常重要，就像在基督教故事中一样。但奥西里斯并不是和耶稣在同一天出生的。这很复杂，因为
you have to map up the Egyptian calendar onto the Greek calendar, onto the Julian calendar, onto the Gregorian calendar. But basically he seems to have been born at kind of early September. This is when the festival is held. Krishna, who is Hare Krishna, all that kind of thing. Is he presented with gold and frankincense and myrrh as a baby? No, he isn't. No evidence for this at all. So all of this is, I don't know where he's, well, I do know where he's got it from. He's basically, he's extrapolating from kind of 19th century scholars who are putting a particular spin on it and he is hyping it up a bit i mean that's essentially where it's kind of come from but there are no ancient sources for any of this but he does mention this god mithras the pre i love a bit of mithras mithras yeah i love
你必须将埃及历法映射到希腊历法、儒略历、格里高利历上。但基本上他似乎是在9月初左右出生的。这就是节日举行的时间。克里希纳，就是哈瑞·克里希纳（Hare Krishna）那一类的。他作为婴儿时收到过黄金、乳香和没药吗？不，他没有。根本没有证据支持这一点。所以所有这些，我不知道他是从哪里……好吧，我知道他是从哪里得到的。他基本上是从19世纪的学者那里推断出来的，那些学者对它进行了特定的解读，而他稍微夸大了一点。我的意思是，这基本上就是它的来源，但没有任何古代文献支持这些说法。但他确实提到了密特拉这个神，前……我喜欢密特拉，密特拉，是的，我喜欢
mithras was he in the world cup of gods can't remember uh he did poorly i think he was and i think he did poorly but what i like about mithras is he was basically, his cult was like a sort of, it's like a version of Freemasonry, wasn't it? For Roman officers. They'd have their little clubs and they'd meet underground and stuff. Right. So is he a pre-Christian god, Mithras, as Sili Tebing claims? Slightly steadier ground here because there is a Persianian god called not mithras but mithra okay who is he's he's kind of pre-zerastrian probably so very very ancient um and mithras is clearly a variant form of of that name mithra and there is a reference to a god called Mithras being worshipped before the birth of Christ. And it comes in Plutarch in his biography of Pompey the Great, Caesar's great rival.
密特拉，他参加过“诸神世界杯”吗？记不清了，呃，他表现很差，我想他表现很差。但我喜欢密特拉的一点是，他的教派基本上就像一种共济会，不是吗？对于罗马军官来说。他们有自己的小俱乐部，在地下聚会之类的。没错。那么密特拉是像李·蒂宾所声称的那样是前基督教神祇吗？这里的基础稍微稳固一点，因为有一个波斯神，不叫密特拉（Mithras）而是叫密特拉（Mithra），他是前琐罗亚斯德教的，可能非常非常古老。密特拉（Mithras）显然是那个名字的变体形式。而且有文献提到在基督诞生之前就有人崇拜一个叫密特拉的神。这出现在普鲁塔克（Plutarch）的《庞培传》（Life of Pompey the Great，凯撒的伟大对手）中。
One of his great feats was to defeat the pirates who were kind of naval terrorists roaming the Mediterranean. And Plutarch says that the pirates who were defeated by Pompey practiced the secret mysteries of Mithras. But the consensus would be that this probably isn't the same as the cult of Mithras that gets practiced by Roman officers, kind of Roman equivalent of Freemasons, because the origins of this seem to be the first century AD and it seems to have originated in Rome, so not in the East. And again, a bit like Freemasonry, that it's a kind of brotherhood that is drawing on all kinds of different traditions to garnish it, to make it look a little bit more kind of exotic. So they basically took the name Mithras
他的一大功绩是击败了在地中海游荡的海盗，那些海盗就像海军恐怖分子。普鲁塔克说，被庞培击败的海盗们信奉密特拉的秘密仪式。但共识是，这可能与罗马军官（罗马版的共济会）所信奉的密特拉教派不是同一个，因为这个教派的起源似乎是公元1世纪，而且似乎起源于罗马，而不是东方。而且，就像共济会一样，它是一种兄弟会，借鉴了各种不同的传统来装饰自己，使它看起来更具异国情调。所以他们基本上采用了密特拉这个名字
from a different religion or Mithra to make themselves seem a bit more glamorous and a bit more exotic and exciting. Yeah. So it's kind of Orientalist, exotic kind of window dressing. So I think that Salih is wrong there. He's also wrong in saying that Mithras was buried in a rock. He wasn't. Instead, Mithras emerges fully formed from a rock, it seems. And there don't seem to be any references at all, certainly that I've been able to find in ancient sources, to his dying and being reborn on the third day. It's important for us to stress this may be Salih Teabing
来自另一个宗教，或者叫密特拉，为了让自己看起来更迷人、更具异国情调和令人兴奋。是的。所以这是一种东方主义的、异国情调的包装。所以我认为李·蒂宾在这里错了。他在说密特拉被埋在岩石里也是错的。他并没有。相反，密特拉似乎是完全成形地从岩石中涌现出来的。而且似乎没有任何文献（至少我能找到的古代文献中）提到他死亡并在第三天重生。强调这一点很重要，这可能是李·蒂宾
making a mistake rather than Dan Brown. Dan Brown may be setting Salih Teabing up as fallible. It could be. I don't think that was the plot twist, as I recall. No, I'm being too generous. Who knows? Who knows? Very unusually, because it's Christmas.
犯了错误，而不是丹·布朗。丹·布朗可能把李·蒂宾设定为一个会犯错的人。有可能。我不记得那是情节反转。不，我太慷慨了。谁知道呢？谁知道呢？非常不寻常，因为今天是圣诞节。
I'm being too kind. You are. You're being kind. Well, it is Christmas, 25th of December, and Salih Teabing is saying that Mithras was born on the 25th of December. And it has to be said that here, he is not alone in making this claim so i'll give you a quote from um a book called stonehenge neolithic man and the cosmos which i was reading a couple of weeks ago in preparation for the court case about the stonehenge tunnel because of course
我太仁慈了。你是。你很仁慈。嗯，今天是圣诞节，12月25日，李·蒂宾说密特拉出生在12月25日。必须说，在这里，他并不是唯一一个提出这种主张的人。所以我给你引用一段话，来自一本叫《巨石阵：新石器时代人类与宇宙》（Stonehenge: Neolithic Man and the Cosmos）的书，几周前为了准备关于巨石阵隧道的法庭案件，我读过这本书，因为当然
you're very keen on that tunnel yeah yeah and this is by by a scholar called John North. He said, the church was anxious to draw the attention of its members away from the old pagan feast days. And the December date did this very well for it coincided with the birthday of the invincible son of Mithraism. But again, there is confusion here. And I should warn people who are listening to this while they're kind of wrestling with brussels sprouts or knocking back another sherry yeah but that there's a certain degree of complexity here so either that's what people want on christmas day probably well i don't know i mean it's it's interesting because it is a kind of detective story okay so i think think of it as a detective story it's kind of sifting the evidence but the evidence is kind of intriguing but there is no
你对那个隧道非常热衷。是的，是的。这是由一位叫约翰·诺斯（John North）的学者写的。他说：“教会急于将成员的注意力从旧的异教节日上转移开。12月的这个日期很好地做到了这一点，因为它与密特拉教的‘无敌太阳’的生日相吻合。”但同样，这里存在混淆。我应该提醒那些在听这期节目时正在和抱子甘蓝搏斗或者又喝了一杯雪利酒的人，是的，这里存在一定程度的复杂性。嗯，这可能是人们在圣诞节想要的东西，大概吧。嗯，我不知道，我的意思是，这很有趣，因为它就像一个侦探故事。好吧，所以把它想成一个侦探故事，这是一种筛选证据的过程，但证据有点耐人寻味，但毫无
denying the fact that we have to dive deep here. The birthday of the invincible son of Mithraism. The invincible son in Latin is Sol Invictus, which is a title that is given to Mithras on various inscriptions that you find in Rome or across the empire. But does this mean that Mithras and the Sol invictus the unconquered son are one and the same and which is basically what's being implied here i think and the answer is no they're not yeah it's a rival cult isn't it son invictus is that their case yeah and so there is there is a kind
否认我们需要深入挖掘的事实。密特拉教的“无敌太阳”的生日。“无敌太阳”在拉丁语中是“Sol Invictus”，这是在罗马或整个帝国发现的各种铭文中赋予密特拉的头衔。但这是否意味着密特拉和“无敌太阳”是同一个神（这基本上就是这里所暗示的），答案是：不，他们不是。是的，这是一个敌对的教派，不是吗？“无敌太阳”是他们的案例，是的。所以有一种
of default assumption that soul invictus the unconquered son, is a cult that gets introduced to Rome from Syria by Elagabalus, who was in the news recently. Yeah. A museum changed his pronouns from he to she. He's been claimed as a transgender emperor. Yes. But Tom, I believe you think that is absolute tosh and nonsense. I don't know, but there is no evidence for it yeah the sources that tell us this are written a long time after his his life for very overt polemical reasons and the sources are very very unreliable so i think it's it's difficult to put much weight on that but he was i mean i see
默认假设，“无敌太阳”是一个从叙利亚被埃拉加巴卢斯（Elagabalus）引入罗马的教派，他最近上了新闻。是的。一家博物馆把他的代词从“他”改成了“她”。他被宣称为跨性别皇帝。是的。但汤姆，我相信你认为那是绝对的胡说八道。我不知道，但没有证据支持这一点。是的，告诉我们这些的文献是在他去世很久之后，出于非常明显的论战目的而写的，而且这些文献非常非常不可靠。所以我认为很难对此给予太多重视。但他确实是，我的意思是，我看到
the word perv written in your notes well this is how he's presented in the in the sources you know so elegabalus the l in that it's the god you god as in Elohim in the Bible. And he's cast as a sun god being introduced to Rome. And it's presumed that until this point, no one in Rome had worshipped the sun. But this is not true. This is patently not true. So Nero's Colossus, for instance, is a statue of the sun. There's a brilliant essay by a Dutch scholar, Stephen Hemans, in which he demonstrates conclusively the presence in Rome of a cult of soul as far back in history as we can trace Roman religion at all. Essentially, the idea that the worship of the unconquered sun is introduced to Rome in the 3rd century AD, it's deriving from essentially
你的笔记里写着“变态”这个词。嗯，这就是他在文献中的呈现方式。你知道，所以埃拉加巴卢斯，其中的“El”是上帝的意思，就像圣经里的“Elohim”。他被塑造成一个被引入罗马的太阳神。人们推测直到这一点，罗马没有人崇拜太阳。但这不真实。这显然不真实。例如，尼禄（Nero）的巨像就是一尊太阳雕像。荷兰学者斯蒂芬·赫曼斯（Stephen Hemans）有一篇精彩的论文，他在其中确凿地证明了罗马存在太阳崇拜，其历史可以追溯到我们能追踪到罗马宗教的最早时期。本质上，认为“无敌太阳”崇拜是在公元3世纪被引入罗马的观点，本质上源于
quite racist preconceptions that scholars in the 19th century have about oriental cults. Right. And they associate it with Elagabalus and they say, he's bonkers. He's dressing up as a woman. He's doing the oriental stuff, talking to the sun, very poor form, et cetera, et cetera. But also that they see worshipping the sun as a kind of oriental cult and therefore it has to be associated with an oriental figure. So this is basically what seems to underpin this. So Mithras and Sol Invictus are definitely separate gods. And in fact, there are Mithraic friezes that show them as separate individuals. But then there's the question, what about Sol Invictus? It's his birthday on the 25th of December. So it's definitely not Mithras. We don't know when Mithras' birthday is. He's not born on the 25th of December because he's not Sol Invictus.
19世纪学者对东方教派相当种族主义的先入之见。没错。他们把它与埃拉加巴卢斯联系起来，说：“他疯了。他打扮成女人。他做那些东方的事情，对着太阳说话，非常不得体，等等。”但也因为他们认为崇拜太阳是一种东方教派，因此它必须与一个东方人物联系起来。所以这基本上就是支撑这一观点的基础。所以密特拉和“无敌太阳”绝对是不同的神。事实上，有密特拉教的浮雕显示他们是不同的人。但随后问题来了，关于“无敌太阳”呢？他的生日是12月25日。所以绝对不是密特拉。我们不知道密特拉的生日是什么时候。他不是出生在12月25日，因为他不是“无敌太阳”。
But what about Sol Invictus? Where does the idea that Sol Invictus has his birthday on the 25th of December come from? Tom, if I'm honest, this is what I previously believed to be true, that Christmas was a rip-off of Sol Invictus' festival. And I'm ashamed to say I may have written a column in BBC History magazine some years ago making this case. Well, you would not be alone. So probably our greatest living historian of paganism, who's been on the rest of history, two brilliant episodes on paganism. Oh, Ronald Hutton.
但关于“无敌太阳”呢？认为“无敌太阳”在12月25日过生日的想法是从哪里来的？汤姆，如果我诚实地说，这曾是我以前认为真实的事情，即圣诞节是抄袭了“无敌太阳”的节日。我很惭愧地说，几年前我可能在《BBC历史杂志》上写过专栏文章来支持这个观点。嗯，你并不孤单。所以，可能我们最伟大的在世异教历史学家，他曾上过《历史的余味》，有两期关于异教的精彩节目。哦，罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）。
Ronald Hutton. Yeah. So in his great book, Stations of the Sun, which is a kind of history of the ritual year in Britain, he talks about Christmas. And this is what he says about it. The first absolutely certain record which places it upon the 25th of December is the calendar of Philokalos, which was produced in 354 and apparently at Rome. He then adds, the reason for the choice of this date and the success of it was stated with admirable candor
罗纳德·赫顿。是的。所以在他那本伟大的书《太阳的站点》（Stations of the Sun）中，那是一本关于英国仪式年度的历史书，他谈到了圣诞节。这就是他关于它的说法：“第一个将它置于12月25日的绝对确凿记录是《菲洛卡洛斯历》（Calendar of Philokalos），它制作于354年，显然是在罗马。”然后他补充说：“选择这个日期的原因及其成功，被一位基督教作家，即4世纪末的‘叙利亚抄写员’（Scriptus Cyrus），以令人钦佩的坦率陈述了出来。”
by a Christian writer, the scriptus Cyrus, in the late 4th century. Hutton then goes on to quote what this figure, this supposed 4th century Christian writer, the Scriptus Cyrus, wrote. He says, so I'm quoting the Scriptus Cyrus here, It was a custom of the pagans to celebrate on the same 25th of December the birthday of the sun, at which they kindled lights in token of festivity. In these solemnities and revelries, the Christians also took part. Accordingly, when the doctors of the church perceived that the Christians had a leaning to this festival, they took counsel and resolved that the true nativity should be solemnized on that day.
赫顿随后引用了这位人物，这位所谓的4世纪基督教作家“叙利亚抄写员”所写的内容。他说（我在这里引用“叙利亚抄写员”的话）：“异教徒习惯在12月25日这一天庆祝太阳的生日，他们在那天点燃灯火以示庆祝。在这些庄严和狂欢中，基督徒也参与其中。因此，当教会的博士们察觉到基督徒倾向于这个节日时，他们商议并决定，真正的圣诞节应该在那一天举行。”
So they completely ripped off the 25th of December Sol Invictus ritual. This is basically what it's saying. And this is the source for the claim that Christians based the 25th of December on the fact that Sol Invictus celebrated his birthday on the 25th of December. But, oh, there's a twist. Don't tell me you're going to bracket Ronald Hudson with Dan Brown, Tom. Well, so the first question, who is the script Osiris? So it literally means a Syrian writer. He is not in fact from the fourth century. Shocking scenes. This is a name that was given in the 19th century and almost all this stuff, all the thing about Christmas being pagan, it's reflecting 19th century scholars who are
所以他们完全抄袭了12月25日的“无敌太阳”仪式。这基本上就是它所说的。这就是关于基督徒基于“无敌太阳”在12月25日庆祝生日这一事实而确定圣诞节的主张的来源。但是，哦，有一个转折。别告诉我你要把罗纳德·赫顿和丹·布朗相提并论，汤姆。嗯，所以第一个问题，谁是“叙利亚抄写员”？所以它字面意思是“叙利亚作家”。他实际上并不是来自4世纪。令人震惊的场景。这是19世纪给出的一个名字，几乎所有这些东西，所有关于圣诞节是异教的东西，都反映了19世纪的学者们，他们
discovering all these new texts or whatever, and working up theories that, say, James Fraser in The Golden Bough is a classic example, that all religions are expressive of certain kind of universal death, resurrection kind of ideas. So they're kind of attuned to look for these parallels and to make them. But the truth is, this is a Syrian text that was discovered in the 19th century by Western scholars. And the scriptosiris, the Syrian writer, is an anonymous scribe who is in the 12th century, so not the 4th century, in the 12th century, is annotating a manuscript by a local bishop. And the quote that Hutton has given,
正在发现所有这些新文本之类的东西，并提出理论，比如詹姆斯·弗雷泽（James Fraser）的《金枝》（The Golden Bough）就是一个典型的例子，认为所有宗教都是某种普遍的死亡、复活观念的表达。所以他们倾向于寻找这些相似之处并制造它们。但事实是，这是一篇在19世纪被西方学者发现的叙利亚文本。而“叙利亚抄写员”，是一位12世纪的匿名抄写员，所以不是4世纪，是在12世纪，正在为一位当地主教的手稿做注释。而赫顿给出的那段引文，
and the quote that people always cite in their things about why Christmas is pagan, they miss out a crucial sentence which precedes it. And this is the sentence. The reason why the fathers of the church moved the 7th of January celebration to the 25th of December was this, they say. So the context for this is that in the East, in Syria, for instance, Christians celebrate Christmas on the 7th or 6th. I can't remember which it is. And the Cyrus Scripter, the Syrian writer, he has met with Christians, Latins from the West
以及人们在谈论为什么圣诞节是异教时总是引用的那段话，他们漏掉了一个关键的句子，它出现在那段话之前。这就是那个句子：“教会之父们将1月7日的庆祝活动移至12月25日的原因是这样的，他们说。”所以这背后的背景是，在东方，例如在叙利亚，基督徒在7日或6日庆祝圣诞节。我不记得是哪一天了。而“叙利亚抄写员”，他遇到了基督徒，来自西方的拉丁人，
because of the Crusades. And he's aware that Christians in the Latin world are celebrating Christmas on a different date to the day that he is. And he's trying to explain it. And of course, he takes for granted that the date on which he and his church are celebrating Christmas day is the authentic one. And therefore, the Christians in Rome and the West have got it wrong. He's trying to say, well, why have they? That basically is the reason. It's not dating from the 4th century. It's his attempt to explain why the Christians in the West have got it wrong, and it's casting aspersions on them. It's designed to be a kind of calumny, basically. However, that said, the reason why this stuck, I think, is because probably the birthday of Sol Invictus was celebrated on the 25th of December.
因为十字军东征。他意识到拉丁世界的基督徒在与他不同的日期庆祝圣诞节。他试图解释这一点。当然，他理所当然地认为他和他的教会庆祝圣诞节的那一天是正宗的。因此，罗马和西方的基督徒搞错了。他试图说，嗯，为什么他们会这样？这基本上就是原因。它不是源于4世纪。这是他试图解释为什么西方的基督徒搞错了，并且是在对他们进行诽谤。它本质上被设计成一种中伤。然而，话虽如此，我认为这个说法之所以流传下来，是因为“无敌太阳”的生日可能确实是在12月25日庆祝的。
So the calendar that Ronald Hutton cited is kind of almanac, and it does date to 354, and it has this entry, n.invicti.cm.xxx. So what does that mean? So the N stands for natalis, so nativity, birth. Invicti, of the unconquered one. CM, it's short for sequences missus, so that means chariot races were ordered. XXX is 30 in Roman numerals. So essentially the translation would be 30 chariot races were ordered to mark the birthday of the unconquered one. So that seems absolutely clear. But of course, unsurprisingly, there are still complexities. Because basically, there are complexities around... These are very fragmentary pieces of evidence on which to build whole castles. So it's not 100% certain, I think,
所以罗纳德·赫顿引用的那个历法是一种年鉴，它确实可以追溯到354年，并且有这样一个条目：“n.invicti.cm.xxx”。那么那是什么意思呢？所以“N”代表“natalis”，即诞生、出生。“Invicti”，无敌者的。“CM”，是“sequences missus”的缩写，意思是下令举行战车比赛。“XXX”是罗马数字30。所以本质上翻译过来就是：下令举行30场战车比赛来纪念无敌者的生日。所以这看起来绝对清楚。但当然，不出所料，仍然存在复杂性。因为基本上，围绕着……这些是非常零碎的证据，不足以建立起整座城堡。所以我认为并不是100%确定，
that Invictus does refer to the sun, to Sol, because there are other entrants that do name-check Sol in the same almanac, and they don't call him Invictus. But let's assume it does refer to Sol. The question is, so this is Hiemann's in his essay, do we know that this feast of Sol on December the 25th antedates the Feast of Christmas at all? Because the major feast day of Sol, and we know this because we have all kinds of references to it, at least back to the time of Augustus, was the 28th of August. This feast then gets supplemented in 274 by the Emperor Aurelian. He's this great conqueror who stitches the
“Invicti”确实指的是太阳，即“Sol”，因为在同一本年鉴中还有其他条目确实提到了“Sol”，但他们没有称他为“Invicti”。但让我们假设它确实指的是“Sol”。问题是（这是赫曼斯在他的论文中提出的），我们知道12月25日的“Sol”节日是否早于圣诞节吗？因为“Sol”的主要节日（我们知道这一点，因为我们有各种各样的文献提到它，至少可以追溯到奥古斯都时期）是8月28日。这个节日随后在274年被皇帝奥勒良（Aurelian）补充。他是一位伟大的征服者，将
fragmenting parts of the Roman Empire back togetherian. He's this great conqueror who stitches the fragmenting parts of the Roman Empire back together again. He's the guy who builds the walls around Rome to protect it. And he is a great enthusiast, it seems, for the worship of Sol, of the sun. And in this almanac, the one that comes out in 354, the one that records the 25th of December as the birthday of the unconquered one. It also specifies that on the 22nd of October, 36 chariot races, so that's six more than on the 25th of December, were staged in honor of Sol. So in other words, this is a bigger celebration of Sol than the 25th of December. So it's possible, I would say even probable, that the birth of Saul on the 25th of December is a feast day, but it's not relative to other feast days, the biggest in the calendar. And the truth is that if you look at the calendar of Roman feast days, there are a
罗马帝国分裂的部分重新缝合在一起。他是那个在罗马周围筑墙保护它的人。而且他似乎非常热衷于对“Sol”（太阳）的崇拜。在这本年鉴中，那本354年出版的、记录12月25日为无敌者生日的那本，它还特别指出，在10月22日，举行了36场战车比赛（比12月25日多了6场），以纪念“Sol”。换句话说，这是比12月25日更盛大的“Sol”庆祝活动。所以换句话说，我甚至可以说这很可能，12月25日太阳的诞生是一个节日，但相对于其他节日，它并不是历法中最大的。事实是，如果你看罗马节日的历法，有很多
lot of them. I mean, there are loads and loads. Every month, there are loads of feast days. They don't have weekends, but they do have feast days. So I would have said that actually, it would be very difficult for, say, Christians to pick a day of the year at random and not have it coincide with some kind of feast day. And then Twitter-based humanists would attack them and say they're just ripping off somebody else. They've got an invented festival and they've just ripped off somebody else's. They'd do that whatever date they've chosen, right? Christians to decide, well, we must mark the birth of our saviour on this day. I mean, I think probably not, because you have this, simply for Sol, you have a bigger festival earlier in the year. Why didn't they go for that? However, the question then is, was there another much more popular festival at around this time in late December that perhaps the Christians could have
很多。我的意思是，有很多很多。每个月都有很多节日。他们没有周末，但他们有节日。所以我本来会说，实际上，基督徒要随机挑选一年中的某一天而不与某种节日重合是非常困难的。然后推特上的人文主义者会攻击他们，说他们只是抄袭了别人的。他们有一个虚构的节日，只是抄袭了别人的。无论他们选择哪一天，他们都会那样做，对吧？基督徒决定，嗯，我们必须在这一天纪念我们救世主的诞生。我的意思是，我想大概不会，因为你有这个，仅仅对于“Sol”，你在一年中更早的时候有一个更大的节日。为什么他们不选那个？然而，问题随后是，在12月下旬左右，是否还有另一个更受欢迎的节日，也许基督徒可以
appropriated. Oh, what a cliffhanger. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back. What drama. Find out what this feast day might conceivably have been. The solution to Tom's Christmas mystery awaits after the break. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
挪用它。哦，真是个悬念。所以我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时。多么戏剧性。找出这个节日可能是什么。汤姆的圣诞之谜的解决方案在休息后揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com
that's therestisentertainment.com The first people to live in Italy were the Aborigines. Their king, Saturnus, is said to have been a man so just that no one lived as a slave nor had any private property for as long as he sat on the throne. Instead, all things were common to all and undivided, as though it were just a single estate for everybody's use. It is to commemorate this way of life, that during the Saturnalia, slaves are mandated to sit down with their masters at banquets, and everyone is held to be of equal rank to everyone
那是 therestisentertainment.com。最早居住在意大利的人是原住民。他们的国王萨图努斯（Saturnus）据说是一个非常公正的人，以至于在他统治期间，没有人过着奴隶的生活，也没有人拥有私有财产。相反，所有事物对所有人来说都是共同的、不可分割的，就像它是供每个人使用的单一庄园一样。正是为了纪念这种生活方式，在农神节（Saturnalia）期间，奴隶们被要求与他们的主人一起坐下来参加宴会，每个人都被认为与其他人地位平等，
else so that's the historian justinus who lived in the second century a.d and he is talking about the jeremy corbin of pre-roman god roman italy the king saturnus so kind that everything was held in common there were no slaves uh life was just one long it was it was a tremendously egalitarian laugh under saturnus wasn't it tom well so saturnus i mean better known as saturn as in the planet right as in the god who gives his name to saturday oh well the king of the aborigines in Italy is actually a god. Is that correct? Yes. Right. Okay. And so he and another god, Janus, who is the god of the new year, because he has two faces looking to the old year and to the new year. The Romans preserved a memory of how these two gods had once ruled over Latium, the area around Rome. Their seat had been the hill that comes to be called the Capitol.
所以这就是生活在公元2世纪的历史学家尤斯蒂努斯（Justinus），他谈论的是前罗马神话中罗马意大利的杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）——萨图努斯国王，他如此仁慈，以至于一切都是共有的，没有奴隶，呃，在萨图努斯统治下，生活简直是一场漫长的、极其平等的笑话，不是吗，汤姆？嗯，所以萨图努斯，我的意思是，更广为人知的是土星（Saturn），就像行星一样，对吧？就像那个给星期六（Saturday）命名为神一样。哦，嗯，意大利原住民的国王实际上是一位神。这是正确的吗？是的。没错。好的。所以他和另一位神，雅努斯（Janus），他是新年的神，因为他有两张脸，一张看着旧年，一张看着新年。罗马人保留了关于这两位神曾经如何统治拉提姆（Latium，罗马周围地区）的记忆。他们的所在地是后来被称为卡皮托利诺山（Capitol）的山丘。
So that's looking down over the Roman Forum, but which before it was called the Capitol, was called the Mons Saturnius, the hill of Saturn. So this is where we're plunging again into deep waters because the question of where Saturn comes from, who he is, what his cult consisted of, is very, very difficult to get a handle on because the origins of these gods are very, very obscure. We just don't have the sources. Of course, the Romans are not writing about their gods as a contemporary anthropologist would. The question of how seriously do they take this stuff, are there variants of the legends, a contemporary anthropologist would. And so the question of how seriously do they take this stuff? Are there variants of the legends?
所以那是俯瞰罗马广场的地方，但在它被称为卡皮托利诺山之前，它被称为“Mons Saturnius”，即萨图努斯之山。所以我们再次陷入了深水区，因为关于萨图努斯来自哪里、他是谁、他的崇拜由什么组成的问题，非常非常难以掌握，因为这些神的起源非常非常模糊。我们根本没有文献。当然，罗马人不像当代人类学家那样书写他们的神。关于他们对这些东西有多认真、传说是否有变体的问题，当代人类学家会这样问。所以关于他们对这些东西有多认真？传说是否有变体？
Very, very complex. So one way always to start with this is to ask, well, what does Saturn mean? And we have a scholar called Pharaoh who lived around the same time as Julius Caesar, who states very clearly that the name of Saturn comes from the Latin word satus, which means the planting or the sowing. However, there are alternative theories also. But of course. So maybe it comes from a town in Latium called Satria.
非常非常复杂。所以开始研究这个问题的总是问，嗯，萨图努斯是什么意思？我们有一位叫瓦罗（Varro）的学者，他生活在凯撒大帝（Julius Caesar）同一时期，他非常清楚地指出，萨图努斯的名字来自拉丁语单词“satus”，意思是种植或播种。然而，也有其他理论。但当然。所以也许它来自拉提姆的一个叫萨特里亚（Satria）的城镇。
When you say Latium, I would say Latium for that. Is it called Latium? Is that what people call it? As in Lazio. As in Lazio, yeah. Lazio. As in Lazio. That's what I was thinking. Latium. I've never heard it called that. But Tom, Latium? Is that what people call it? As in Lazio. As in Lazio, yeah. Lazio. As in Lazio. That's what I was thinking of. Latium. I've never heard it called that, but Tom,
当你提到拉提姆（Latium）时，我会说“Latium”。它叫“Latium”吗？那是人们称呼它的方式吗？就像拉齐奥（Lazio）。就像拉齐奥，是的。拉齐奥。就像拉齐奥。这就是我所想的。拉提姆。我从来没听过它被那样称呼。但汤姆，拉提姆？那是人们称呼它的方式吗？就像拉齐奥。就像拉齐奥，是的。拉齐奥。就像拉齐奥。这就是我所想的。拉提姆。我从来没听过它被那样称呼，但汤姆，
I bow to your expertise. That's how I've always called it. Maybe I've got it wrong. I don't know. And there's a third theory, which is that the Etruscans worshipped a god called Satre. And we know about this because in 1877, a weird, it's a bronze model of a sheep's liver. Okay. And livers would be inspected by Etruscan priests. It was found at Piacenza in Tuscany, so in the homelands of the Etruscans. And a portion of this liver is holy to this god satra who appears to be a very
我向你的专业知识致敬。我一直都是这样称呼它的。也许我弄错了。我不知道。还有第三种理论，即伊特鲁里亚人（Etruscans）崇拜一位叫萨特雷（Satre）的神。我们知道这一点是因为在1877年，一个奇怪的……这是一个羊肝的青铜模型。好的。肝脏会被伊特鲁里亚祭司检查。它是在托斯卡纳的皮亚琴察（Piacenza）发现的，也就是在伊特鲁里亚人的家乡。这个肝脏的一部分是神圣的，属于这个神萨特雷，他似乎是一个非常
menacing god he has a thunderbolt but otherwise we know absolutely nothing about him okay so it's not entirely helpful but i've said the likeliest explanation he's something to do with perhaps the harvest and perhaps the saturnalia is staged to celebrate uh the end of the harvest or something like that but but it's late though because it's december so hold on tom you this this podcast is just overturning a lot of things that i thought so saturn has nothing to do with he's not a greek god we'll come to that oh we'll come to that okay so the ravens start associating their gods with greek gods as they become more familiar with the Greek world.
具有威胁性的神，他有一个雷电，但除此之外我们对他一无所知。好的，所以这并不是很有帮助，但我说过最可能的解释是，他可能与收获有关，也许农神节是为了庆祝收获结束之类的，但它很晚，因为是在12月。所以等等，汤姆，你……这个播客推翻了很多我以为的事情，所以萨图努斯与……他不是希腊神，我们稍后会谈到。哦，我们稍后会谈到。好的，所以罗马人开始在他们变得更熟悉希腊世界时将他们的神与希腊神联系起来。
That's right. So in the third, second century. He's not Kronos. We'll come to that. But just at the moment, just looking at what seems to be the most primordial stories that are told about Saturn. So his temple is the oldest, according to priestly records, is the oldest in the forum. You can still see the base of it.
没错。所以是在3世纪、2世纪。他不是克洛诺斯（Kronos）。我们稍后会谈到。但目前，只是看看关于萨图努斯的最原始的故事。所以根据祭司记录，他的神庙是广场上最古老的，你仍然可以看到它的基座。
It's at the foot of the Palatine near the Capitol. Oh it was consecrated in 497 BC. And the worship of Saturn traditionally was said to be even older than that. So he's a very, very venerable God. And the proof of the fact that to the Romans, that his worship was older, in fact, even than the founding of Rome itself, is that sacrifices at his altar were made in the Greek manner. So Romans make sacrifice by putting their togas up over their heads. So if you think of, there's a famous statue of Augustus as a priest and he has his head, he has the toga over his head like a kind of veil. But they do it in the Greek manner,
它位于卡皮托利诺山附近的帕拉蒂尼山脚下。哦，它是在公元前497年被祝圣的。而萨图努斯的崇拜传统上被认为比那还要古老。所以他是一位非常、非常受人尊敬的神。而且对于罗马人来说，他的崇拜实际上比罗马本身的建立还要古老的事实证明是，在他祭坛上的祭祀是以希腊方式进行的。所以罗马人通过把托加长袍拉到头上来进行祭祀。所以如果你想到，有一尊著名的奥古斯都作为祭司的雕像，他把头……他把托加长袍像面纱一样盖在头上。但他们以希腊方式进行，
i.e. bareheaded, and this is before the coming of Aeneas to Rome. So essentially, they're dating the worship of Saturn in the forum, what will become the forum, to before Aeneas, who's in the long run, his line will give rise to Romulus and Remus and the founding of Rome. So very, very ancient. And the stories that are told about Saturn, and it's hinted in that passage from Justinus that you were quoting, is that he was a king who ruled over a golden age. And the Romans called it the Saturnia Regna, no slaves, everyone shares property in common, kind of wonderful. And in the Aeneid, the great poem that is written by Virgil to celebrate the origins of Rome. Aeneas is a Trojan prince who escapes the sack of Troy and is destined to give rise in the long run to Rome.
即赤裸着头，这是在埃涅阿斯（Aeneas）来到罗马之前。所以本质上，他们将广场（即后来的广场）上萨图努斯的崇拜定位于埃涅阿斯之前，从长远来看，他的血统将产生罗慕路斯（Romulus）和雷穆斯（Remus）以及罗马的建立。所以非常非常古老。而关于萨图努斯的故事（在尤斯蒂努斯引用的那段话中有所暗示）是，他是一位统治黄金时代的国王。罗马人称之为“Saturnia Regna”，没有奴隶，每个人共同分享财产，非常美妙。而在《埃涅阿斯纪》（Aeneid）中，那首由维吉尔（Virgil）为庆祝罗马起源而写的伟大诗篇中。埃涅阿斯是一位特洛伊王子，他逃离了特洛伊的洗劫，注定从长远来看会产生罗马。
Saturn is cast as the god who introduces civilization to the region around Rome, and he is welcomed there by Janus, this two-headed god. He establishes his seat on what will become the Capitol. So to quote Virgil, Saturn's reign was the age of gold, men like to say. So peacefully calm and kind, he ruled his subjects. But little by little, a lesser tarnished age came stealing in, filled with the madness of war, the passion for possessions. So this is the great Roman idea. There was a golden age and then gradually turned to iron. And you can trace a kind of family tree. So he gives birth to a king called Pecus, which is a Latin for woodpecker.
萨图努斯被塑造成将文明引入罗马周边地区的神，他在那里受到了雅努斯（这位双面神）的欢迎。他在后来被称为卡皮托利诺山的地方建立了他的所在地。所以引用维吉尔的话：“萨图努斯的统治是黄金时代，人们喜欢这样说。他如此和平、冷静和仁慈地统治着他的臣民。但一点一点地，一个较小的、被玷污的时代悄悄进入，充满了战争的疯狂、对占有的热情。”所以这是伟大的罗马思想。曾经有一个黄金时代，然后逐渐变成了铁器时代。你可以追溯一种家谱。所以他生下了一个叫佩库斯（Pecus）的国王，这是拉丁语中啄木鸟的意思。
And there are various theories, again, as to why. Did he use woodpeckers to tell the future, or was he turned into a woodpecker by the sorcerer Circe? I mean, all kinds of things. He, in turn, is succeeded by Faunus, so as in faun, who has goat's heads. And by the time of Caesar, so Cicero, the great scholar, orator, Caesar's contemporary, he says, I've got no idea who or what Faunus was. So even the Romans themselves are kind of confused by this. But I think the central idea of Saturn
关于为什么，又有各种各样的理论。他用啄木鸟来预测未来吗？还是他被女巫喀耳刻（Circe）变成了啄木鸟？我的意思是，各种各样的事情。他反过来由福努斯（Faunus）继位，就像牧神一样，他有山羊的头。到了凯撒时代，所以西塞罗（Cicero），那位伟大的学者、演说家、凯撒的同代人，他说：“我不知道福努斯是谁或是什么。”所以即使是罗马人自己也对此感到困惑。但我认为萨图努斯的核心思想
is that he rules over a golden age. And this is the tradition that kind of passes into the bloodstream of Roman culture. But inevitably, there is also a counter-theory. Oh, we love a counter-theory on The Rest is History. That in a way, he is a symbol of the savagery that had existed before the coming of civilization. So not a golden age at all, quite the reverse. So there are hints in Christian writings, and Christians obviously have their own agenda.
就是他统治着一个黄金时代。这就是那种融入了罗马文化血液的传统。但不可避免地，也存在一种反面理论。哦，我们在《历史的其余部分》节目中非常喜欢反面理论。即在某种程度上，他是文明到来之前所存在的野蛮的象征。所以根本不是什么黄金时代，恰恰相反。因此，在基督教著作中存在一些暗示，而基督徒显然有他们自己的议程。
I mean, they absolutely have reasons to make Saturn look as bad as possible. But they claim that during the Saturnalia, gladiatorial entertainments are staged and that the gladiators who die in these are being offered up to Saturn as offerings. And it does seem to be the case that he is seen as being quite menacing because his cult statue in his temple in the Forum, his ankles are bound by thick wool. So they're kind of symbolizing the fetters that make him dangerous. And this, I think, is why you mentioned Kronos. So Kronos is the Greek for time. He's the father of the gods, at least the leading gods and goddesses.
我的意思是，他们绝对有理由让萨图恩看起来尽可能糟糕。但他们声称，在农神节期间，会举行角斗士表演，而在这些表演中死去的角斗士被当作祭品献给萨图恩。而且他似乎确实被视为相当具有威胁性，因为他在广场神庙里的崇拜雕像，他的脚踝被厚厚的羊毛束缚着。所以他们是在象征那些使他变得危险的枷锁。我认为，这就是你提到克洛诺斯的原因。所以克洛诺斯是希腊语中的“时间”。他是众神之父，至少是主要的男神和女神之父。
And he's been told that he will be overthrown by his son, by one of his children. And so he devours them. And the only one who manages to get away is Zeus, who comes to be equated by the Romans with Jupiter, the king of the gods. And the equation of Saturn with Kronos does make him seem a more kind of a sinister figure. I mean, he eats his children and that's unacceptable behavior. Very bad conduct. Yeah.
他被告知他会被他的儿子，也就是他的一个孩子推翻。于是他吞噬了他们。唯一设法逃脱的是宙斯，他后来被罗马人等同于众神之王朱庇特。而将萨图恩与克洛诺斯等同起来，确实使他看起来更像是一个阴险的人物。我的意思是，他吃掉自己的孩子，那是不可接受的行为。非常糟糕的品行。是的。
Even for a god. Yeah. Yeah. So basically, Saturn embodies two contradictory theories. He's a menacing tyrant who defiles his children and who got overthrown by Zeus and fled to Italy. Or he's a king who ruled over a golden age and his temple is still in the forum and people worship him. It's all over the place, Tom. It's all over the shop. Yeah, it absolutely is all over the place. But I think that, I mean, this is when I said that it can be treacherous to explore the history of these gods and even to try and work out
即使对于一个神来说也是如此。是的。是的。所以基本上，萨图恩体现了两种矛盾的理论。他是一个亵渎自己孩子并被宙斯推翻后逃往意大利的威胁性暴君。或者他是一位统治着黄金时代的国王，他的神庙至今仍矗立在广场上，人们崇拜他。这太混乱了，汤姆。简直是一团糟。是的，这绝对是一团糟。但我认为，我的意思是，这就是我所说的，探索这些神的历史，甚至试图弄清楚
what they meant to the Romans, because often they do embody incredibly contradictory traditions. And the Romans are fine with that. Yeah, they are fine with that because presumably the reality is that these gods mean different things to different people at different times. I mean, we're talking about a vast span of history, hundreds and hundreds of years. So the meaning of these gods will have changed, presumably during this period. They will have changed, but I think that they can mean different things to different people at the same time. It's kind of that complicated. But there's no question that the great feast day of Saturn is on the 17th of December. Now note, not the 25th of December, the 17th of December.
它们对罗马人意味着什么，可能会很棘手，因为它们往往体现了极其矛盾的传统。而罗马人对此并不介意。是的，他们不介意，因为大概事实是，这些神在不同的时间对不同的人意味着不同的东西。我的意思是，我们谈论的是一段漫长的历史，几百几百年。所以这些神的含义大概在这段时期内发生了变化。它们确实会发生变化，但我认为它们可以在同一时间对不同的人意味着不同的东西。就是这么复杂。但毫无疑问，萨图恩的盛大节日是在12月17日。注意，不是12月25日，是12月17日。
And this feast is the Saturnalia. Very, very highly loved festival. I mean, loved in the way that Christmas is loved by us. It's the day of the year that people look forward to. So much so that rather as with our Christmas day, that the festive season extends much beyond Christmas. Likewise, by first century BC, essentially the Saturnalia has come to last for a week. It runs until the 23rd of December. Augustus, who's very conservative, he doesn't approve of innovation. He says that it should be only three days. Augustus is very much kind of, why are people putting up Christmas decorations in August? Kind of a guy.
这个节日就是农神节。非常、非常受欢迎的节日。我的意思是，就像我们喜爱圣诞节那样喜爱它。这是人们一年中翘首以盼的日子。以至于就像我们的圣诞节一样，节日季远远超出了圣诞节本身。同样，到了公元前一世纪，农神节基本上已经持续了一周。它一直持续到12月23日。奥古斯都，他非常保守，他不赞成创新。他说应该只有三天。奥古斯都非常像那种会说“为什么人们在八月就挂圣诞装饰？”的人。
I mean, that's absolutely what he'd be on. And he's saying, you know, it shouldn't be seven days. We'll have it three days. But then Caligula, who's very much a guy who likes a party, he says, no, we'll push it back. We'll have four days. So we, in Suetonius, to give a permanent boost to the gaiety of the nation,
我的意思是，这绝对是他会做的事。他说，你知道，不应该是七天。我们只过三天。但后来卡里古拉，他非常喜欢聚会，他说，不，我们要推迟它。我们要过四天。所以我们，在苏埃托尼乌斯那里，为了给国家的欢乐带来永久的提升，
he added an extra day to the Saturnaliaalia which he called the festival of the young so i don't know he's appealing to the youthful constituencies he's pandering and uh seneca great philosopher yeah tutor of nero hated caligula with a passion and he kind of grumbles that once december was a month now it fills the year so So again, that's very familiar. So this might seem a parallel, as does the fact that Saturnalia, it's a time where people enjoy themselves, but it is also a feast day of the God. So it is holy to the God. And it's on this day that the woolen fetters around his ankles in the temple are removed. There is this public sacrifice done in the Greek style, so bareheaded. There is a great public banquet held at which a statue of the God is laid down on a couch. So kind of like he's come to take part in the fun. And you have
他给农神节增加了一天，他称之为青年节，所以我不知道，他是在吸引年轻选民，他在迎合，呃，塞内卡，伟大的哲学家，是的，尼禄的导师，非常痛恨卡里古拉，他抱怨说曾经十二月是一个月，现在它填满了全年，所以，这又非常熟悉了。所以这看起来可能是一个平行点，就像农神节是一个人们享受自己的时间，但它也是神的一个节日。所以它对神来说是神圣的。就在这一天，神庙里他脚踝上的羊毛枷锁被解开了。有这种希腊式的公开祭祀，所以是赤着头的。举行了一场盛大的公开宴会，神像被放在长椅上。就像他来参加娱乐活动一样。你有
these cries of Io Saturnalia. Io Saturnalia. What's that mean? It means brilliant. Saturnalia is here. Hooray. Okay. Have fun. Okay. Let's celebrate. Kind of happy Christmas.
这些“Io Saturnalia”的呼喊。Io Saturnalia。那是什么意思？意思是太棒了。农神节到了。万岁。好的。玩得开心。好的。让我们庆祝吧。有点像圣诞快乐。
Yeah. And it's hugely, hugely look forward to, as I said. And I think that, is it Christmas though? I think it's more like the festivals you get at Carnival than Christmas. So it's all about the subversion of convention. And to the Romans, conventions are very, very important. But this is the day, this is the season when you can overturn things. So men and women alike go about wearing this item of clothing called a synthesis, which is a costume that initially seems to have been female and traditionally
是的。正如我所说，人们非常、非常期待它。而且我认为，它是圣诞节吗？我认为它更像狂欢节而不是圣诞节。所以它完全是关于颠覆传统。对于罗马人来说，传统非常、非常重要。但这是你可以颠覆事物的一天，这个季节。所以男人和女人都穿着一种叫做“合成服”的衣服，这是一种最初似乎是女性的服装，传统上
is only worn at dinner parties. But Roman men on the Saturnalia, they take off their toga and they put on this synthesis. So it's subversive both because it's men wearing a quite feminized item of clothing, but also because you are wearing something that you should probably only wear at a dinner party out on the streets. So it's a bit like as if blokes were wearing ball gowns on christmas day not quite yeah yeah leotard perhaps or something yeah or cocktail dress perhaps or something like that yeah i'm not going to adopt that ritual myself by the way so there's gender confusion okay there's confusion of proprieties there is also very famously and this is hinted
只在晚宴上穿。但在农神节，罗马男人脱下托加长袍，穿上这种合成服。所以它具有颠覆性，既因为男人穿着相当女性化的服装，也因为你穿着一种可能只应该在晚宴上穿的衣服走在街上。所以这有点像男人们在圣诞节穿舞会礼服，不太像，是的，也许是紧身衣之类的，是的，或者鸡尾酒裙之类的，是的，顺便说一句，我不会自己采用那种仪式。所以有性别混乱，好的，有礼仪混乱，还有非常著名的一点，这在
at in that passage that you read from Justinus, it's probably the one thing that everyone knows about the Saturnalia, which is that it's a great day for slaves. So free people will wear the Palaeus, which is the liberty cap that is given to freed men. So again, that's a kind of subversion of traditional orders. Slaves are allowed to talk back to their masters if they want to, and they are served at dinner by their master and they're allowed to eat first. So this is turning, again, the kind of traditional proprieties absolutely on its head. You also have riotous drinking, gambling, which normally is illegal. This has become legal. And you get groups of people they
你读的那段查士丁尼的文字中有所暗示，这可能是每个人都知道的关于农神节的一件事，那就是这对奴隶来说是一个伟大的日子。所以自由人会戴上“皮勒斯”帽，这是给被释放的奴隶的自由帽。所以这又是一种对传统秩序的颠覆。奴隶如果愿意，可以顶撞他们的主人，他们在晚餐时由主人伺候，而且他们被允许先吃。所以这再次将那种传统的礼仪完全颠倒了过来。你还有狂乱的饮酒、赌博，这通常是非法的。这变得合法了。而且你有一群人，他们
rather like we celebrate christmas i suppose kind of you know you meet up and have um we're feeling a little bit hungover aren't we a little bit fragile as we record this if yourself tom because yesterday yesterday we had the rest is history christmas lunch and what we did we served the producers of that didn't we we did yes we went and got of that, didn't we? We did, yes. We went and got the Guinness, got the wine. Yeah. So rather in a similar way, groups of friends would get together and they would choose a princeps or a rex, so an emperor or a king, who would organise pranks and japes.
就像我们庆祝圣诞节一样，我想，你知道，你聚在一起，我们有点宿醉，不是吗？当我们录制这个节目时，我们有点脆弱，如果你自己，汤姆，因为昨天，昨天我们举行了《历史的其余部分》圣诞午餐，我们做了什么，我们招待了制作人，不是吗？我们确实这样做了，是的，我们去拿了吉尼斯黑啤，拿了葡萄酒。是的。所以以类似的方式，朋友们会聚在一起，他们会选择一个“首领”或“国王”，也就是皇帝或国王，他会组织恶作剧和玩笑。
Oh, japes. Yeah. And pranks. I'm not sure I approve of pranks and japes, to be honest with you. So Lukin, who is a second century writer, he writes of how fun it is to become, in a quote, the supreme master of everyone
哦，玩笑。是的。还有恶作剧。老实说，我不确定我是否赞成恶作剧和玩笑。所以卢基安，一位二世纪的作家，他写道，成为，引用一下，“每个人的最高主人”是多么有趣，
with a win at the knucklebone. So they roll the knucklebones to decide who's going to become the princeps. So that not only do you get out of having to follow embarrassing orders yourself, but you get to make all your friends do as you say. You can order one man to yell out some disgraceful secret about himself and order another to
通过赢得指关节骨游戏。所以他们掷指关节骨来决定谁将成为“首领”。所以你不仅不用自己去执行令人尴尬的命令，而且你可以让所有的朋友都听你的。你可以命令一个人大声说出关于他自己的某个可耻的秘密，命令另一个人
dance naked, pick up the flute girl and carry her around the room three times. I'm so glad we didn't tell the producers this before we had Akris for Slush. And it's obviously, you know, you're called a princeps. It's a parody of the powers that the emperor has over, you know, all his fellow citizens. And there's a notorious occasion where a future emperor does get voted princeps. This is Nero. And according to Tacitus, Nero gets voted princeps of their kind of group of friends. And he gets his stepbrother Britannicus, who is the son of Claudius, to stand in the middle of the party and sing a song. And Britannicus sings a sad song about how Claudius, his dad, is shoving him to one side and allowing Nero perhaps to become emperor.
裸体跳舞，抱起笛女绕房间走三圈。我很高兴我们在吃圣诞午餐之前没有告诉制作人这些。这显然，你知道，你被称为“首领”。这是对皇帝对他所有公民拥有的权力的模仿。有一个臭名昭著的场合，未来的皇帝确实被选为“首领”。这就是尼禄。根据塔西佗的说法，尼禄被他那群朋友选为“首领”。他让他的继兄弟不列塔尼库斯，也就是克劳狄乌斯的儿子，站在聚会中间唱一首歌。不列塔尼库斯唱了一首悲伤的歌，关于他的父亲克劳狄乌斯是如何把他推到一边，让尼禄可能成为皇帝的。
So it could be a moment for pathos as well as fun. The one thing about it that is kind of reminiscent of Christmas, and I think it's the thing that people always pick up on, is that people gave each other presents. So they give each other candles and they give each other dolls that are called sigillaria. Some of these are images of gods. Some of them are kind of images of hunchbacks or grotesques or whatever. Mostly they're very cheap. They're kind of mass-produced, but they can be very rich, kind of very expensively done. Macrobius, who is a guy writing in the Christian period, the late fourth century, and he's very, very nostalgic for the festivities of the Saturnalia,
所以这可能是一个既有悲情又有乐趣的时刻。关于它的一点确实让人想起圣诞节，我认为这是人们总是注意到的事情，那就是人们互相赠送礼物。所以他们互相赠送蜡烛，他们互相赠送被称为“小塑像”的玩偶。其中一些是神的形象。其中一些是驼背或怪诞的形象等等。大多数都很便宜。它们是批量生产的，但它们也可以非常昂贵，制作得非常精美。马克罗比乌斯，一个生活在基督教时期，即四世纪末的人，他对农神节的庆祝活动非常、非常怀旧，
and he and his friends have a big debate about what are these dolls? Are they substitutes for the sacrifices that were originally made to Saturn? Or are they just toys? And they can't decide, which is quite a kind of modern sounding debate. I mean, it sounds like the kind of debates that, you know, scholars would have today. Definitely, yeah. And also the other thing is that you give gifts of mincemeat that are not actually made of mincemeat. They're made of clay or plaster or whatever. Okay. That's a bit weird.
他和他的朋友们进行了一场关于这些玩偶是什么的大辩论。它们是最初献给萨图恩的祭品的替代品吗？还是它们只是玩具？他们无法决定，这听起来是一种相当现代的辩论。我的意思是，这听起来像是今天学者们会进行的辩论。绝对是，是的。还有另一件事是，你赠送肉馅饼的礼物，但实际上并不是用肉馅做的。它们是用粘土或石膏之类的做的。好的。这有点奇怪。
It is a bit weird. Franz Dupont, who writes, she's written a brilliant book on everyday life in the Roman Republic, daily life in ancient Rome. She writes about the Saturnalia. For one day, nothing was as it seemed, neither the relationships between people nor the presence that changed hands. Order would return on the following day. Anarchy, chance, deceptive appearance. The Saturnalia was the flip side of the true life of Roman citizens. And so it seems to be a kind of safety valve to slaves, to cast off the kind of the traditional order. On the thing with the slaves, I mean, presumably there were bounds that they couldn't overstep.
这确实有点奇怪。弗朗茨·杜邦，她写了一本关于罗马共和国日常生活、古罗马日常生活的精彩书籍。她写了关于农神节的内容。有一天，一切看起来都不一样了，无论是人与人之间的关系，还是易手的礼物。秩序会在第二天恢复。无政府状态、偶然、欺骗性的外表。农神节是罗马公民真实生活的另一面。所以它似乎是奴隶的一种安全阀，可以摆脱那种传统的秩序。关于奴隶的事情，我的意思是，大概有一些他们不能逾越的界限。
So, you know, they can talk back to their masters. But I mean, the next day they're going to be slaves again and their masters will remember. So it's probably not quite as, this wonderful release. Because it must be, to some degree, if you've got a very horrible master, the whole thing must just be this grotesque parody that you have to go through. Anyway, sorry sorry go on no no you're i mean you're absolutely right uh that of course every slave knows that once the saturnalia is gone you know the master can absolutely punish you for anything that you said yeah um but i think i think the idea is that it gives you know a slave it gives a slave the chance
所以，你知道，他们可以顶撞他们的主人。但我的意思是，第二天他们又要成为奴隶了，他们的主人会记住的。所以这可能并不完全是这种美妙的释放。因为如果你有一个非常可怕的主人，整个事情一定只是你必须经历的一种怪诞的模仿。总之，抱歉，抱歉，继续，不，不，你是，我的意思是，你是绝对正确的，当然每个奴隶都知道，一旦农神节结束，你知道，主人绝对可以因为你说的任何话而惩罚你。是的，嗯，但我认为，我认为这个想法是，它给了，你知道，一个奴隶，它给了奴隶一个机会
to make a complaint that he or she might think that the owner would be amenable to. I mean, I think it's kind of a little bit like that. But you're right that, of course, there are lots of people who don't like it, chiefly intellectuals. Some intellectuals seem to have really disliked the Saturnalia. They never like fun, do they? Let's be honest. No. So Seneca, who we've already mentioned, complaining about the fact that the Saturnalia. They never like fun, do they? Let's be honest. No. So Seneca, who we've already mentioned, complaining about the fact that the Saturnalia goes on all year. He hates having to discard his toga
去提出一个他或她认为主人可能会接受的抱怨。我的意思是，我认为这有点像那样。但你是对的，当然有很多不喜欢它的人，主要是知识分子。一些知识分子似乎真的很讨厌农神节。他们从来不喜欢乐趣，不是吗？老实说。不。所以塞内卡，我们已经提到过，抱怨农神节的事实。他们从来不喜欢乐趣，不是吗？老实说。不。所以塞内卡，我们已经提到过，抱怨农神节持续了一整年。他讨厌不得不脱掉他的托加长袍，
because he feels that it infringes his dignity. And he says that it's disrespectful to the ancestors of the Roman people who had only ever discarded their togas when the Republic was in peril and fallen on evil days. And Pliny the Younger, who's an absolute funster, when everybody is having fun and celebrating Saturnalia, he retreats to his study and reads. Oh, well, you can read it. I sometimes read at Christmas. Yeah.
因为他觉得这损害了他的尊严。他说，这对罗马人民的祖先是不尊重的，他们只有在共和国处于危险之中、陷入困境时才会脱掉托加长袍。而小普林尼，一个绝对的享乐主义者，当每个人都在享受乐趣和庆祝农神节时，他退到书房里读书。哦，好吧，你可以读书。我有时在圣诞节读书。是的。
Well, reading is a nice thing to do at Christmas. Yeah, but not if you've invited guests over. And they're all having fun. I mean, I suppose it's kind of like small children rushing around screaming high on sugar. And you think, well, I'm going to go home. I'll read some Dickens. Read some Dickens in my study. But it has to be said that Roman poets seem to have adored it.
嗯，读书是圣诞节做的一件好事。是的，但如果你邀请了客人来就不行了。他们都在玩得很开心。我的意思是，我想这有点像小孩子在糖分的作用下尖叫着跑来跑去。而你心想，好吧，我要回家了。我要读一些狄更斯。在我的书房里读一些狄更斯。但必须说，罗马诗人似乎很喜欢它。
So Catullus, great love poet, contemporary of Julius Caesar. He called it the best of days. Yeah. Statius, poet writing under Domitian. He celebrated a lavish saturnalia that had been hosted by by the emperor and um horace intriguingly gives us a flavor of what it might have been like outside rome because he in one of his poems he describes how every december there's this kind of this local cult this village feast which is in honor not of saturn but of faunus the the kind of you know the the king with the with the goat horns and it sounds
所以卡图卢斯，伟大的爱情诗人，尤利乌斯·凯撒的同时代人。他称之为“最好的日子”。是的。斯塔提乌斯，在多米提安统治下写作的诗人。他庆祝了一场由皇帝主持的奢华的农神节，而且，呃，贺拉斯有趣地给了我们一个关于罗马城外可能是什么样子的味道，因为他在他的一首诗中描述了每年十二月都有这种地方崇拜，这种乡村节日，不是为了纪念萨图恩，而是为了纪念法乌努斯，那种，你知道，长着山羊角的国王，听起来
quite like the saturnalia so he he sacrifices lots of produce he throws big parties lots of presents go out you know it's a season of plenty and then they all go out into the into the fields and they they all have a big dance big knees knees up, surrounded by their cattle, and it all sounds great fun. So I think philosophers, intellectuals, they don't like Saturnalia. Poets, they absolutely seem to have loved it. And I think it's clear from this that December was associated with merrymaking, and that the Saturnalia, it clearly has influenced the Faunus out in the fields. The question then is, did it influence other cults? Christianity. Right. So salient factors. It's not the same date. We've already pointed that out.
很像农神节，所以他牺牲了很多农产品，他举办大型聚会，送出很多礼物，你知道，这是一个丰收的季节，然后他们都走到田野里，他们都跳了一场大舞，大狂欢，被他们的牛群包围着，听起来很有趣。所以我认为哲学家、知识分子，他们不喜欢农神节。诗人，他们绝对似乎很喜欢它。我认为从这一点可以清楚地看出，十二月与狂欢有关，而且农神节显然影响了田野里的法乌努斯。那么问题是，它是否影响了其他崇拜？基督教。对。所以显著因素。日期不一样。我们已经指出了这一点。
The two festivals are actually celebrated simultaneously throughout late antiquity. So you can do the Saturnalia and then you can do Christmas. So it's not like they've very obviously been merged. They're seen as being separate as late as the fourth century into the fifth century. Would people do both if you're a bit promiscuous about your religion? I mean, there are Christians who really hate this, but yes, I think that there are people who are doing both. So you could say, well, it's a season of goodwill. Yeah. But I think that the Saturnalia is arising from things that are to do with Saturn. You know, it's, as you'd expect, presents, no. Christmas, the tradition of present giving is, I mean, it's basically, I think it's 15th century.
这两个节日实际上在整个古代晚期是同时庆祝的。所以你可以过农神节，然后你可以过圣诞节。所以它们看起来并没有很明显地合并。直到四世纪到五世纪，它们仍被视为是分开的。如果你对你的宗教有点滥交，人们会两者都做吗？我的意思是，有真正讨厌这一点的基督徒，但是的，我认为有人两者都做。所以你可以说，嗯，这是一个善意的季节。是的。但我认为农神节是源于与萨图恩有关的事情。你知道，正如你所料，礼物，不。圣诞节，送礼的传统是，我的意思是，它基本上，我认为是15世纪的。
Ah, so Saturnalia has presents, but Christmas doesn't. No. Interesting. No, it's kind of early modern phenomenon. Right. This idea of electing a princeps who can, you know, organize fun. So that seems quite like the Lord of Misrule that you get in Christmas celebrations. And the idea that the Lord of Misrule, the medieval Lord of Misrule, is descended from
啊，所以农神节有礼物，但圣诞节没有。不。有趣。不，这是一种近代早期的现象。对。这种选举一个可以，你知道，组织乐趣的“首领”的想法。所以这看起来很像你在圣诞庆祝活动中得到的“混乱之王”。而且“混乱之王”，中世纪的“混乱之王”，是源于
the kind of Saturnalian figure is very, very popular in the late Victorian period. So James Fraser, who wrote The Golden Bower, he's all over that. But the Lord of Misrule is a medieval tradition. There doesn't seem to be anything that joins it to antiquity. So basically, it seems convergent evolution. So the way that just because a bird, a pterosaur, and a bat all have wings doesn't mean that they have all evolved from one another. And of course, the whole idea that Christmas festivities originated in Saturnalian celebrations, it doesn't originate with atheists or humanists. It originates with Puritans who want to abolish all this kind of merrymaking. So the Cromwellians, yeah.
那种农神节的人物，在维多利亚时代晚期非常、非常流行。所以詹姆斯·弗雷泽，写了《金枝》，他对此非常了解。但“混乱之王”是一个中世纪的传统。似乎没有任何东西将它与古代联系起来。所以基本上，这似乎是趋同进化。所以就像鸟、翼龙和蝙蝠都有翅膀，并不意味着它们都是从彼此进化而来的。当然，整个圣诞节庆祝活动起源于农神节庆祝活动的观点，它不是起源于无神论者或人文主义者。它起源于想要废除所有这种狂欢的清教徒。所以克伦威尔派，是的。
Yeah. And so they recognize, I think, that these celebrations, you know, they're an inheritance from the Catholic past, from before the Reformation. And casting them as pagan, it makes it easier for them to abolish them. So I don't think that there are really any links at all between the Saturnalia and Christmas. Really? Controversial. They're both in December, and you can imagine why you'd want to celebrate, have fun in the depth of darkness. The darkest depths of the winter, exactly.
是的。所以他们认识到，我想，这些庆祝活动，你知道，它们是天主教过去的遗产，来自宗教改革之前。把它们定性为异教，使他们更容易废除它们。所以我认为农神节和圣诞节之间真的没有任何联系。真的吗？有争议。它们都在十二月，你可以想象为什么你想在黑暗的深处庆祝、玩乐。冬天的最黑暗深处，正是如此。
The darkest depths. But that then raises, I suppose, raises the question, well, did Christians deliberately choose December the 25th for that reason? I mean, I don't think they choose it because it's the birthday of Sol and Victor. I don't think they choose it because of Saturnalia, for the reasons that I've explained. And actually, we know, I think, why the Christians choose December the 25th, despite the fact that there is no evidence whatsoever in the Gospels for him being born on that day. And they do it quite late. So the reason that it takes Christians so long, we said that the earliest
最黑暗的深处。但这随后引发了，我想，引发了一个问题，好吧，基督徒是否因为那个原因故意选择了12月25日？我的意思是，我不认为他们选择它是为了它是索尔和维克托的生日。我不认为他们因为农神节而选择它，原因我已经解释过了。事实上，我们知道，我想，为什么基督徒选择12月25日，尽管福音书中没有任何证据表明他出生在那一天。而且他们做得相当晚。所以基督徒花这么长时间的原因，我们说最早的
mention of Christmas being celebrated on the 25th of December isn't until the middle of the fourth century. And the reason for that, I think, is that Christians viewed the celebration of birthdays as a pagan practice. So Oregon, the great philosopher, possibly a eunuch, he writes commentary on the gospel of St. Matthew. And in it, he observes that we learn from scripture that no birthday was ever celebrated by a righteous man. Why? Why wouldn't you celebrate someone's birthday? Mad. It's seen as a thing that pagans do. It's not something that Jews, and therefore by extension, Christians are doing. So then why did they start doing it in the mid-fourth century? And I think it's all to do with debates about who or what Christ was. To what extent is he divine? To what extent is he human?
提到圣诞节在12月25日庆祝要到四世纪中叶。我认为原因在于，基督徒将生日庆祝视为一种异教习俗。所以奥利金，伟大的哲学家，可能是个太监，他写了关于圣马太福音的评论。在其中，他观察到我们从经文中了解到，没有一个义人庆祝过生日。为什么？为什么你不庆祝某人的生日？疯了。这被视为异教徒做的事情。这不是犹太人，因此延伸到基督徒所做的事情。那么为什么他们在四世纪中叶开始这样做呢？我认为这完全与关于基督是谁或什么的辩论有关。他在多大程度上是神圣的？他在多大程度上是人类？
And there are lots of people, lots of Christians who are saying that Christ is purely divine, and therefore the man Jesus is born, and then the divine Christ enters him. This is not what comes to be orthodoxy. So at the Council of Nicaea in 325, they declare that Jesus is God of God, light of light, very God of very God, but also that he came down and was incarnate, i.e. made flesh and was made man. So therefore, if you're trying to see off people who think that Jesus wasn't really man, it's important to identify his birthday. And that's why I think it's shortly after the Council of Nicaea that you start getting celebration of his birthday. But that, of course, still doesn't explain why it's the 25th of December.
而且有很多人，很多基督徒说基督是纯粹神圣的，因此人耶稣出生了，然后神圣的基督进入了他。这不是后来成为正统的东西。所以在325年的尼西亚会议上，他们宣布耶稣是神之神，光之光，真神之真神，但也说他降临并道成肉身，即成为肉身并成为人。因此，如果你试图避开那些认为耶稣不是真正的人的人，确定他的生日很重要。这就是为什么我认为在尼西亚会议之后不久，你就开始庆祝他的生日了。但这当然仍然不能解释为什么是12月25日。
And I think that, as you would expect, the reason for it lies in Christian reasons, just as the Saturnalia is held for reasons that have to do with the worship of Saturn. So Christmas is celebrated on the day it is for reasons that have to do with the inheritance of Jewish tradition. And both Jewish and Christian scholars are very, very into the idea that the great calendar of the ages has an inherent symmetry. So Jewish scholars, they argue that the creation of the world, the birth of Abraham, Abraham's heirs, that they are all born on the same day that will be the day when the Messiah is born and Israel gains its redemption. So this idea that there's a kind of a patterning that's stamped by God on the flow of time. And Christian scholars inherit this. And for the same reason, they come to believe that Jesus had died on the anniversary of his incarnation. So in other words, Christ comes into the world
我认为，正如你所料，其原因在于基督教的原因，就像农神节举行是因为与萨图恩的崇拜有关一样。所以圣诞节在这一天庆祝是因为与犹太传统的继承有关。犹太学者和基督教学者都非常、非常热衷于这样一个想法，即伟大的时代历法具有内在的对称性。所以犹太学者认为，世界的创造、亚伯拉罕的出生、亚伯拉罕的后裔，他们都出生在同一天，那将是弥赛亚出生和以色列获得救赎的日子。所以这种上帝在时间流逝中盖上的某种模式的想法。而基督教学者继承了这一点。出于同样的原因，他们开始相信耶稣死于他道成肉身的周年纪念日。所以换句话说，基督来到这个世界
on the same day that he leaves it. And there is therefore a kind of a perfect symmetry to the structure of his life and death we say uh he came into the world is that being born or being conceived no it's the incarnation so it's when the archangel gabriel appears to the virgin mary right and jesus becomes incarnate right he is conceived in her womb and this date for complicated reasons that i won't go into right but it's to do with the dating of the Passover and all kinds of things. Christians, first in Carthage and then in Rome, come to identify this with the 25th of March. So this is Lady Day.
在他离开它的同一天。因此，他的生与死的结构有一种完美的对称性，我们说，呃，他来到这个世界，那是出生还是受孕？不，是道成肉身，所以是天使长加百列向圣母玛利亚显现的时候，对，耶稣道成肉身，对，他在她的子宫里受孕，这个日期出于我不会深入探讨的复杂原因，但它与逾越节的日期和各种各样的事情有关。基督徒，先是在迦太基，然后在罗马，开始将其与3月25日联系起来。所以这是圣母领报节。
It's the day that Tolkien identifies as being the day on which the ring is thrown into the crack of doom. To Mount Doom. It's the holiest day of the year. I mean, Tolkien, of course, absolutely knew this. And this beds down, I think, over the second, the third, into the fourth century. And of course, once you've worked out that the incarnation is the 25th of March, then nine months on from that is the 25th of December. And I think that that is how you get it. And that's absolutely
这是托尔金认定为戒指被扔进末日裂缝的那一天。到末日火山。这是一年中最神圣的日子。我的意思是，托尔金当然绝对知道这一点。我认为这在二世纪、三世纪、四世纪期间扎根。当然，一旦你算出道成肉身是3月25日，那么九个月后就是12月25日。我认为这就是你得到它的方式。而且那绝对是
what you would expect because you would expect, you know, this is unbelievably holy for Christians. They're not going to nick it from the worship of a sun or from Saturn. And I think the whole, as I said, the whole reason why they start celebrating Christmas is because it's about one faction of Christians trying to make a point to another faction of Christians. Those are the people that they're conscious of. They're not interested in what pagans are doing. So they're basically reminding the other Christians, they're saying, Christ was human as well as divine, and let's have a massive party on his birthday to remind… Well, not have a party, but I think at that point, because we don't really know how they're celebrating it.
你会预料到的，因为你会预料到，你知道，这对基督徒来说是难以置信的神圣。他们不会从太阳神或萨图恩的崇拜中窃取它。而且我认为整个，正如我所说，他们开始庆祝圣诞节的全部原因是因为这是一个派系的基督徒试图向另一个派系的基督徒表达观点。那些是他们意识到的人。他们对异教徒在做什么不感兴趣。所以他们基本上是在提醒其他基督徒，他们说，基督既是人也是神，让我们在他的生日举行一场盛大的聚会来提醒……嗯，不是举行聚会，但我认为在那一点上，因为我们真的不知道他们是如何庆祝它的。
So we don't know what they were doing when they start celebrating Christmas. Not really. There's probably a lot of singing hymns and praying. Probably, but we know that over the course of the centuries that follow, of course it becomes the great feast day. It is a time of celebration. Because in the depth of winter, you do want to have a celebration and i thought dominic oh that we might end with some roman festive music would you like that oh tom i would love that as long as
所以我们不知道他们开始庆祝圣诞节时在做什么。不是真的。可能有很多唱赞美诗和祈祷。可能，但我们知道在随后的几个世纪里，它当然成为了盛大的节日。这是一个庆祝的时刻。因为在冬天的深处，你确实想举行庆祝活动，我想多米尼克，哦，我们可能会以一些罗马节日音乐结束，你想要那样吗？哦，汤姆，我很乐意，只要
you're not going to be singing i would really enjoy that no i'm not so this is this is the choir of saint bartholomew the Great, who last Wednesday, they did a medieval carol service. And one of the hymns that they sang was written by St. Ambrose in the fourth century. It's a properly Roman hymn. And Ambrose is a very Roman figure. He'd been a governor in Milan. And then everyone in Milan said, said no we don't want you as a governor we want you as a bishop and so he obedient to that he became one of the great fathers of the church and he wrote this hymn veini redemptor gentium which is come redeemer of the peoples of the world redeemer of the nations um so it's an advent hymn yeah so we probably shouldn't be
你不会唱歌，我会非常享受的，不，我不会，所以这是大圣巴塞洛缪唱诗班，上周三，他们举行了中世纪颂歌仪式。他们唱的赞美诗之一是圣安布罗斯在四世纪写的。这是一首真正的罗马赞美诗。安布罗斯是一个非常罗马的人物。他曾是米兰的总督。然后米兰的每个人都说，说不，我们不想要你做总督，我们想要你做主教，所以他顺从了这一点，他成为了教会的伟大教父之一，他写了这首赞美诗《Veini redemptor gentium》，也就是“来吧，世界万民的救赎主”，所以这是一首降临节赞美诗，是的，所以我们可能不应该
putting it out on the 25th of december because course Christ has come, but what the hell it's a, it's a Roman hymn. It's festive. And so, uh, I think a perfect way to end this episode and to wish everyone a very, very happy Roman Christmas. Well done, that was fantastic. Uh, Merry Christmas, everybody. And take it away, please, Ambrose. Sint urgentium, postenne parfum virtis, mire et oramne seculum, aris tecet parfus Deum. Non ex vivis semine, ser mystico spiramine, verbum Dei facur est paro, rupusque ventris floruit. Albus fulvescit virgilis, claustrum pui dodis
在12月25日发布它，因为基督已经来了，但管他呢，这是一首罗马赞美诗。它是节日的。所以，呃，我认为结束这一集并祝愿大家有一个非常、非常快乐的罗马圣诞节的完美方式。做得好，那太棒了。呃，圣诞快乐，大家。请开始吧，安布罗斯。Sint urgentium, postenne parfum virtis, mire et oramne seculum, aris tecet parfus Deum. Non ex vivis semine, ser mystico spiramine, verbum Dei facur est paro, rupusque ventris floruit. Albus fulvescit virgilis, claustrum pui dodis
permanent, vexima virtutum micant, versatul in templo Deo. Proceda tecana noso, oonis auta regia, genine giga substantiae, allae que sut currat via. Amen. firma nostrii corponis, virtutae firmans perpeti. Pressepe iam fulget tu, lo lengue nox pirat novum, quod nulla nox interponent, fideque iurgi luceant. SET CHRISTIM REX VESIME, TIBI PATRIQUE GLORIA, Tivi Patrique Gloria Cum Spiritul Paracleto
Insem Viterna Secula Amen Amen. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
Insem Viterna Secula Amen Amen. 我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。